what's the craziest thing you've ever
seen scoring Dr in the streets of
Baltimore one night I got stabbed in the
head I was running this room from this
guy it's an abandoned house but I'd pay
him $10 a night to sleep in this
abandoned house and it's like 400 in the
morning and I'm I'm leaving the house to
go secure my finances for the day
whether it's robbing cheating whatever I
have to do and um as I walk down the
stairs it's a really sad sight there's
this woman a net and this woman robing
and a baby in a carriage and they're
smoking crack and the baby's crying the
woman with the baby she yoked me up and
put me in this headlock and she's like
give me the money give me the money and
I had $10 hidden in my sock but I
refused to give the $10 up the baby's
crying they smoking crack it's 400 in
the morning in this really like terrible
part of Baltimore city and the net hands
Robin what I think is a knife who then
proceeds to start stabbing me in the
head finally after like the fourth
puncture I I pull the 10 bucks out and I
I give it to him and I see that she
stabbed me in the head with an ink pen
and I like made it out Jesus like oh
it's a pen give me back my 10